it was really wild getting married this
year we were going to get married on
august 1st
i think come hell or high water whether
that meant nobody could be there
or a million people could be there we
just
really had been waiting for a while to
get married and i'm so excited
that we were able to do it with uh with
a small group of of our closest friends
and family
um and it has it has been a strange year
you know um
but we made the best of it we did what
we could and
um you know i'm very thankful for that
the time at home has been something
that i'm not accustomed to uh but
something that i that i'm very grateful
for
uh to be able to spend time with my wife
and and just for us to enjoy each
other's company
uh and tonight is just a cherry on top
of that so it's it's been really great
how is getting married and winning this
win changed your perspective for this
year
you know uh i i constantly think about
how lucky i am
and and how grateful i am to be in the
situation that i am and
and to get married this year was was a
really amazing
amazing bright spot in my life uh as
well as
as 2020 which has been a really strange
year and
to have tonight on top of it and and
just to be with a really small
concise group of of people that i love
and people that i enjoy being around
has just been amazing you know i could
have never imagined
uh taking two awards home tonight and
i'm just thankful for my team
and for my wife and for my family and
for the fans and uh
i'm just grateful to to be the guy
standing here talking to you that's all
just curious when you uh when you
announced your song tonight
you said that you know it was a new one
that you'd written for your wife
did she know that was going to happen or
was that just another nice wedding
present for her
no she she's heard that one you know uh
i wrote that
in boone north carolina where i went to
college i
usually do a little writing retreat up
there every year and we wrote that
probably a year and a half ago
in seven devils north carolina super
super small place and
my my wife was there with me and some of
my co-writers dan is bull and randy
montana and
we started the song there and then
finished it out back in nashville and
it was always special you know and
nicole has been a constant theme
uh throughout the last couple of years
in my life in my music
and and she keeps me real grounded and
provides constant inspiration for songs
and so
um you know i always try to to pay a
little bit of homage to her and
i'm just thankful that people are loving
this tune and i'm excited for people
to get to hear it on the radio and
excited to bring something a little bit
more stripped down
uh to the airwaves and pumped it that
the acms would let me do that tonight